kommen wir zur debatte zur politik der
bundesregierung beim bundesministerium
und wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
das ist ja ein neu geschaffenes
ministerium vorher lag die zuständigkeit
für den bau beim innenministerium
also bei horst seehofer csu jetzt liegt
es bei klara geywitz die wir hier schon
was sehen sie wird auch als erste
sprechen und das ist dieses ministerium
gibt es auch ein zeichen dass hier eben
bauen und wohnen zur chefsache gemacht
werden soll also ein ministerium mit
einer engen vertrauten von bundeskanzler
olaf scholz klara geywitz sie werden
sich vielleicht daran erinnern hatte
damals zusammen mit olaf scholz auch für
den spd parteivorsitz
beworben
bekanntermaßen hat es nicht geklappt
jetzt plant sie unter anderem jährlich
400.000 wohnungen neu zu bauen davon
sollen 100.000 sozialwohnungen sein
und wie sie das schaffen möchte kann sie
jetzt in der rede ich hier noch einmal
erörtern
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren abgeordnete
wohnen dass es ein menschenrecht so ist
es im internationalen pakt für
wirtschaftliche soziale und kulturelle
rechte festgelegt es ist gerade kein
luxus für wenige sondern lebensgrundlage
für alle und ich füge hinzu gutes und
bezahlbares wohnen in einem lebenswerten
umfeld
es ist aus meiner sicht eine frage des
respekts dass diejenigen die hart
arbeiten gut davon leben und auch gut
davon wohnen können es ist ausdruck des
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalts dass
azubis familien und rentnerinnen und
rentner tür an tür miteinander leben
können dass er ist es auch eine frage
der zukunftsfähigkeit unseres landes
ob wir es schaffen ausreichend wohnungen
zu bauen die den demographischen den
digitalen erfordernissen und den
ökologischen standards unserer
gesellschaft entsprechen
damit das gelingt ist viel zu tun
deshalb ist es wichtig dass die
fortschritts koalition ein
eigenständiges bundesministerium
geschaffen hat zum ersten mal
zum ersten mal seit sage und schreibe
1998 gibt es dieses ministerium wieder
das unterstreicht nicht nur die
politische bedeutung des wohnungsbaus
und der stadtentwicklung es ist auch die
chance unter einem dach und aus einer
hand die themen wohnen stadtentwicklung
und bauwesen vom bund aus neu zu denken
die chance neue wege zu beschreiten und
innovationen zu ermöglichen
und natürlich auch eine chance die
gewaltige transformation der
bauwirtschaft aktiv zu gestalten und für
neuen ökonomischen schub in deutschland
zu sorgen
für diese politischen ziel werde ich
schnell ein stabiles fundament bauen
indem wir schwung in dem wohnungsmarkt
bringen wir brauchen viel mehr
bezahlbaren und klimaneutralen
wohnungsbau
400.000 neue wohnungen sollen pro jahr
gebaut werden können davon 100.000 im
sozialen wohnungsbau deswegen werde ich
das bündnis bezahlbarer wohnraum zügig
auf setzen gemeinsam
gemeinsam in ländern die nun der bau und
wohnungswirtschaft mitmieter verbänden
gewerkschaften aber auch vielen weiteren
akteuren werden wir dafür sorgen dass es
gelingt und ich weiß dafür braucht es
natürlich zum einen wichtigen förderer
aber auch zum anderen die wichtigen
rahmenbedingungen
deswegen war eine meiner ersten
amtshandlungen die soziale
wohnraumförderung für 2022 auf den weg
zu bringen noch im dezember konnten wir
eine milliarde euro bundesmittel für den
sozialen wohnungsbau freigeben eine
weitere milliarde aus dem klima paket
wird folgen
wenn wir bezahlbare wohnungen schaffen
wollen brauchen wir aber noch mehr
zuallererst genügend bauland
brachliegende grundstücke bei den
einzelnen auf wertsteigerung spekulieren
können wir uns nicht mehr leisten
wichtig ist auch dass sie schnell wieder
rechtssicherheit haben beim
vorkaufsrecht und wir da eine gute
lösung nach dem urteil des
bundesverwaltungsgerichtes finden
meine damen und herren baum ist alltag
für viele jede und jeder der in den
letzten monaten versucht hat ein
bauvorhaben oder eine renovierung
anzugehen kennt das problem das eine ist
das notwendige baumaterial das anderes
der handwerker dazu die bewältigung des
fachkräftemangels wird deshalb eine der
großen zentralen aufgaben bei der wir
innerhalb der bundesregierung aber auch
gemeinsam mit unternehmen und
gewerkschaften an einem strang ziehen
müssen wir brauchen eine zugelaufene sie
so wir brauchen weiterbildung fachkräfte
einwanderung und gute arbeitsbedingungen
auf dem bau
damit wir beim bauen einen gang höher
schalten werden wir die planungs und
bauphase fahren vereinfachen tempo
machen wir auch durch die nutzung
digitaler verfahren denn auch dafür ist
mein haus mit zuständig weniger
bürokratie und mehr standardisierung
übrigens wollen wir beim bundesbau
schneller werden wir wollen eine
vorbildfunktion einnehmen und zeigen wie
effizientes und nachhaltiges bauen geht
bei diesen block west in berlin-mitte
können sie sich das schon mal ansehen es
hat vom prüfauftrag des zur
finalisierung nur 27 monate gedauert
übrigens in modernen und modulen holzbau
es war die bundesverwaltung doch die
große zahl an wohnungen die wir bauen
wird nicht von heute auf morgen gebaut
genauso wichtig ist deshalb eine rasche
entlastung auf angespannten
wohnungsmärkten die mieten müssen in den
nächsten jahren bezahlbar bleiben auch
und gerade wenn es modernisiert und
energetisch saniert wird dabei geht es
nicht nur um die kaltmiete die
energiepreise machen vielen große sorgen
deshalb ist bereits zum jahreswechsel
für mehr als eine million bürgerinnen
und bürger ein höheres wohngeld in kraft
getreten und ich möchte noch einmal
ergänzen wohngeld beziehen sollen einen
einmaligen heizkostenzuschuss von
mindestens 135 euro erhalten und es war
unser großes anliegen dass wir das so
schnell wie möglich auf den weg bringen
für 710000 raushalten die davon
profitieren
[Applaus]
verständlich haben wir uns auch auf
verbesserungen bei der miete denn gut
wurden heißt auch keine angst zu haben
seine wohnung gegen mietsteigerungen zu
verlieren die koalition hat sich
verständigt die mietpreis bremse bis
2029 zu verlängern begrenzungen bei
mieterhöhungen angespannten wurden
märkten und eine ausweitung des
mietspiegels vorzunehmen und ich möchte
auch dafür sorgen sich um die menschen
sorgen die gar keine wohnung haben bis
20.30 wollen wir als bundesregierung die
obdach und wohnungslosigkeit überwinden
deshalb ist mir als bau und
wohnungsmieterin der nationale
aktionsplan dafür sehr wichtig
meine damen und herren wir starten in
ein transformation jahrzehnt in dem wir
unser land beim klimaschutz auf kurs
bringen mit guter gesetzgebung
entschlossenheit und experimentierfreude
können wir hier viel erreichen
ich freue mich dass ich auch mit dem
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck schon
verabreden konnte dass wir themen
gemeinsam angehen zum beispiel die
nachhaltigkeit und die bezahlbarkeit
beim bauen und wohnen maßnahmen für
energieeffiziente gebäude oder eine
fachkräfte strategie gerade im bau
handwerk und das forschen an
nachhaltigen baustoffen erste maßnahmen
werden wir schon im klimaschutz
sofortprogramm auf den weg bringen und
mein wunsch wäre es dass wir zum
beispiel ganz konkret in deutschland die
bedingungen für mieter strom noch weiter
verbessern
nicht zuletzt sich das auf als meine
aufgabe für gutes leben in stadt und auf
dem lande zu sorgen dafür nehme ich die
quartiers stadt und regionalentwicklung
mit in den blick gutes wohnen und leben
braucht ein gutes und lebenswertes
umfeld ich bin übrigens sehr froh
darüber dass in meinem haus und auch die
raumordnung verortet ist das hilft enorm
und bei der planung und innovativen
entwicklung von regionen schneller zu
werden klimawandel strukturwandel
demografischer wandel sozialer
zusammenhalt und digitalisierung das
sind nur einige der stichworte die den
riesigen transformations- bedarf in
städten und gemeinden beschreiben mit
der städtebauförderung haben wir ein
schlagkräftiges instrument dieses werden
für für gutes leben und zusammenhalt in
stadt und land weiter verbessern ich
freue mich dass wir zum beispiel 250
millionen euro in 238 städte investieren
können gerade um die von corona sehr
stark in mitleidenschaft gezogenen
innenstädte zu stabilisieren und neue
formen auch von gemeinplätzen zu
schaffen wo man sich jenseits eines
kommerziellen einkaufserlebnisses in der
innenstadt aufhalten kann gerade auch
familie und diese beleben
integrierte mobilitätskonzepte
[Applaus]
mobilitätsangebote insbesondere mit
ländlichen gebieten müssen dazu realität
werden unsere lebensräume müssen klima
resilient werden und sich vor den folgen
von starkregen ereignissen und
hitzeperioden zu schützen hier gibt es
viel zu investieren in der
städtebauförderung und auch in der
regionalplanung vielleicht noch ein satz
zur region bonn ich weiß sie erwartet
von uns auch ein bekenntnis zur
bundesstadt bonn von mir wird sie dies
bekomme ich fahre demnächst in die
region in den rhein sieg kreis sprecher
auch mit der oberbürgermeisterin und wir
werden uns sehr viel zeiten eben auch
mit dem kommunalen expertise um zu
schauen wie wir auch die bundesstadt
bonn stärken konnten herzlichen dank
vielen dank frau ministerin
schnitzel die kurze pause eine anmerkung
frau ministerin bei aller wertschätzung
für die ausführung der regierung will
ich darauf hinweisen dass die tatsache
dass auf louis block west 400
büroeinheiten zwischen errichtet werden
konnten jedenfalls auch dem wird mit
aller fraktionen dieses hauses in der
bauraum kommission zu danken ist also
nicht nur der regierung so viel
wahrheit muss sagen da wird nicht
einfach die jungs auch dankbar so
nächster redner einiges mit erste locker
ja den master
krimi mystery
checks cdu csu fraktion
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
kollegen und kollegen ein dach über dem
kopf zu haben das ist ein menschliches
bedürfnis ein existenzielles bedürfnis
eine wohnung zu haben ist aber noch weit
mehr eine wohnung ist auch immer
persönlicher rückzugsraum ort der
individuellen entfaltung und somit auch
ein stück heimat und wohnungspolitik hat
daher für jeden einzelnen für familien
aber auch für die gesellschaft insgesamt
eine enorm hohe bedeutung die
immobilienwirtschaft ist auch
volkswirtschaftlich essentiell für unser
land 3,3 millionen arbeitsplätze gibt es
dort in diesem bereich die
bruttowertschöpfung beträgt über 600
milliarden euro weit mehr als das etwa
in der automobilindustrie der fall ist
und auch für den klimaschutz das thema
was es in den letzten jahren so enorm
bewegt und auch in den kommenden jahren
bewegen wird wird das thema sind die
gebäude ganz essentiell und zentral 35
prozent des endenergieverbrauchs
werden im gebäudebestand verbraucht 30
prozent der co2 emissionen werden dort
im etihad hier schlummern also riesige
potenziale die wir heben können und
wollen wenn der klimaneutralität
erreichen wollen und deswegen begrüßen
wir als union ausdrücklich dass es in
dieser wahlperiode ein eigenständiges
ressort für bauen und wohnen gibt damit
geht dann aber auch die erwartungen her
dass das thema bauen und wohnen
innerhalb der ampel sichtbarkeit und das
gewicht bekommt dass ihnen angesichts
ihrer bedeutung für die menschen für die
gesellschaft und auch den klimaschutz zu
kommen und so für ein sehr geehrte frau
ministerin zu ihrer ernennung
beglückwünschen wir sie ganz
ausdrücklich für diesen geschäftsbereich
wir wünschen ihnen für diese wichtige
aufgabe alles gute und viel erfolg und
wir sagen ihnen auch zu dass wir als
fraktion sie dabei konstruktiv begleiten
und unterstützen werden wenn sie gute
vorschläge machen um den
herausforderungen dieser zeit
nachzukommen und die herausforderungen
die herausforderung in diesem ressort
die sind groß sie haben sich ehrgeizige
ziele gesetzt das zentrale ziel sie
haben es erwähnt sind 400.000 wohnungen
die jedes jahr neu entstehen sollen 1,6
millionen wohnungen in dieser
wahlperiode mehr bauen das ist auch aus
unserer sicht der richtige weg um die
angespannten wohnungsmärkte bei angebot
und nachfrage endlich wieder ins
gleichgewicht zu bringen nur auf diesem
wege werden wir die steigenden
mietpreise auch nachhaltig in den griff
bekommen und verhindern dass menschen
verdrängt werden und insofern begrüßen
wir dass das die bauoffensive die wir
als union in der letzten wahlperiode
gestartet haben dass die jetzt von der
ampel auch mit fortgesetzt wird das ist
ein gutes und richtiges signal und sie
vor ministerin sie haben es in einem
ihrer ersten interviews gesagt sie
werden an diesem ziel all dieser
erwartung auch gemessen werden 1,6
millionen wohnungen in dieser
wahlperiode unserer beratung als union
ist es daher dass die vielen hürden die
es gibt um dieses ziel zu erreichen dass
sie diese beseitigen dass sie die
bürokratischen hemmnisse angeben dass
sie die 20.000 bauvorschriften die es in
unserem land gibt dass sie die radikal
entschlacken dass sie die planungs dauer
beschleunigen dass sie die mobilisierung
von bauland voranbringen dafür müssen
sie die richtigen rahmenbedingungen
schaffen und wenn sie das angehen wollen
da reichen wir ihnen als union gern die
hand dazu
uns ist aber wichtig dass
wir sie dann auch nicht an ihrer dass
sie uns nicht an ihrer seite haben wenn
sie die steigenden mietpreise allein
durch regulierungen versuchen in griff
zu kommen wir haben in dem bereich des
mietrechts in der letzten wahlperiode
viel auf den weg gebracht ich will das
hier gar nicht im einzelnen ausgeglichen
was wir aber jetzt sagen können dass wir
die ersten erfolge sehen die
leerstandsquote
zeigt erstmals als 15 jahren leicht und
auch in einigen wachstumsregionen das
ist mir ganz wichtig oder auch die
neuvertragsmieten haben nicht mehr die
dynamik die sie in den letzten jahren
gehabt haben sondern auch in einigen
bereichen verzeichnen wir da sogar
rückwände das ist immer noch auf
niedrigem niveau gar keine frage aber
trotzdem können wir feststellen langsam
entspannt sich die lage wieder auf dem
wohnungsmarkt wir haben wir eine
trendumkehr und deswegen finde ich das
was sie jetzt gerade auch sagten zum
mietpreis bringen sie dass sie die
verlängern wollen das finde ich schon
bemerkenswert bis 2029 wollen sie die
mietpreis bremse verlängern obwohl wir
sie gerade erst vor gar nicht allzu
langer zeit bis 2025 verlängert haben
sie zementieren damit einen
markteingriff von dem wir heute noch gar
nicht wissen ob er in einigen jahren
überhaupt noch erforderlich ist wenn
diese trendumkehr sich fortsetzt also
wir weitere signale der entspannung auf
dem wohnungsmarkt haben dann ist das
auch verfassungsrechtlich höchst
problematisch
ob die verlängerung einer solchen
mietpreis bremse überhaupt richtig und
erforderlich wäre sie wissen es das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat in seinem
beschluss zur neat was würden sie
ausdrücklich ausgeführt dass die
zeitliche befristung für die
verfassungsrechtliche eigenen
rechtfertigung
für diesen eingriff in das eigentum
zentrales und deswegen darf es keine
vollständige entkopplung von den
marktpreisen geben sonst kommen wir in
die substanz verletzung des eigentums
und deswegen sagen wir aus diesen
befristeten instrument darf keine
dauerlösung werden ohne rücksicht auf
die lage am wohnungsmarkt meine damen
und herren
wichtig ist wenn sie die menschen
wirklich helfen wollen dann müssen sie
die baukosten in den griff bekommen 14
prozent steigerungen haben wir hier
zuletzt verzeichnen können und deswegen
ist es auch gut und richtig dass die
baukosten lenkungs kommission ihre
arbeit fortsetzen soll da habe ich
überhaupt gar nichts gegen mir ist aber
wichtig zu sagen die haben doch nicht
primär ein erkenntnisproblem sondern wir
haben doch vor allen dingen ein
durchsetzungs problem und deswegen ist
es so wichtig frau ministerin sie müssen
die beschlossenen die diskutierten
maßnahmen jetzt endlich auch um und
durchsetzen das ist wichtig damit wir
nicht zu steigenden baukosten kommen war
das immer auch bedeutet dass die
wohnkosten steigen und das dann auch am
ende die mieten steigen und deswegen
darf es nicht zu kommen die baukosten
müssen runter frau ministerin und
deswegen sehen wir sorge dass der
koalitionsvertrag nachgerade gespickt
ist mit vorhaben die das bauen am ende
deutlich vor anderen werden kfw 40
standard für den neubau im bestand
wesentliche aus und umbauten er 70
standard solardach pflicht 65 prozent
erneuerbare energien für den einbau
neuer heizungen all das ist ein
widerspruch wenn sie die baukosten
senken wollen und deswegen ist das
natürlich ein zielkonflikt das wissen
wir sie haben es im ausschuss gesagt es
ist ein bisschen die quadratur des
kreises wir hoffen und wir haben auch
die erwartungen an sie dass sie
denjenigen auch in ihrer koalition die
dort überbordende regulierung fantasien
haben dass sie denen die stirn bieten
dass wir zu einem vernünftigen ausgleich
kommen zwischen ökologie und ökonomie
dass die baukosten nicht durch die decke
gehen meine damen und herren und am ende
möchte ich noch ein thema ansprechen
weil sie es auch nicht erwähnt haben
frau ministerin wenn ich richtig
zugehört habe das wort eigentumsbildung
ist in ihrer rede nicht ein einziges mal
vorgekommen nicht ein einziges mal der
traum vom eigenheim davon träumen vier
von fünf menschen in deutschland sie
wollen in die eigenen vier wände aber
lebend diesen trauben viel zu wenige
deutschland ist bei der eigentumsquote
schlusslicht in europa und zuletzt sogar
zurückgefallen und deswegen finden wir
das also nun richtig dass sie im
koalitionsvertrag sagen wir wollen
eigenkapital ersetzt eine dame in
tilgungszuschüsse zinsverbilligung
freibeträge bei der grunderwerbsteuer
aber sie bleiben bei all diesen punkten
im ungefähren sie sagen sie wollen das
aber sie sagen ich sie werden das
umsetzen und wenn wir jetzt mal nach
hamburg schauen wo auch eine ampel
reagiert da haben sie gerade die
grunderwerbssteuer erhöht und deswegen
sagen wir an dieser stelle sie müssen
ein klares signal aussenden an all die
menschen die eigentum bilden wollen in
diesem land dass sie das auch
ermöglichen werden sie müssen klar sagen
welche mittel sie zur verfügung stellen
und ihnen die steine in den weg legen
wenn sie das tun und dann habe die union
an ihrer seite aber wenn es um
regulierung geht und steigende baukosten
da wäre mehr steine in den weg legen
vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
[Applaus]
für bündnis 90 die grünen spricht nun
christina johannes schröder sie ist
sprecherin für wohnen stadtentwicklung
bauwesen und kommunen hier im deutschen
bundestag
bündnis 90 die grünen zum ersten
parlaments
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident werte
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren es ist so cool das wohn ganz vorn
am titel des neuen ministeriums steht
wie wir wohnen das ist das erste mit dem
wir am morgen konfrontiert werden ist es
laut oder leise oder saniert habe ich
und meine familie genug platz einen
langen weg zur schule oder zur arbeit
kann ich mir gutes wohnen leisten oder
belastende mieten bodenpreise oder
wohnnebenkosten stark man hört ganz oft
dass die frage des hohns zu einer großen
sozialen frage geworden ist entscheidend
für den zusammenhalt in der gesellschaft
sogar die union war zu dieser analyse
fähig taten haben sie im gegensatz dazu
fahrlässig vermissen lassen und
zugesehen wie mieten boden und bau
kosten explodieren
[Applaus]
herr dr
auch für sie
preise für wohngebäude sind zwischen
2010 und 2020 um 29 prozent gestiegen
für zweifamilienhäuser
eigentumswohnungen und einfamilienhäuser
umsatz auf 65 prozent
nur woran liegt das dass nicht doch
nicht dass wir mehr dämmen oder meine
solaranlage aufs ausklappen das liegt
daran dass sich die kosten für bauland
mehr als verdoppelt haben ihnen meisten
regionen sogar mehr als verdreifacht
[Applaus]
nach jahren der blockade durch die union
werden wir wir die ampel das baurecht
vereinfachten und wird samt das
mietrecht nachschärfen und schön dass
die union dabei konstruktiv die
mitarbeit angekündigt hat wer die ampel
koalition wollen eben genau diese
rahmenbedingungen dafür setzen dass
400.000 neue wohnungen geschaffen werden
davon hunderttausend sozial gebunden und
durch erleichterungen baurecht für
aufstockungen dachausbau und umnutzung
geringer genutzter flächen entsteht ein
potenzial von unglaublichen 2,5
millionen wohnungen ohne eine weitere
fläche zu segeln ohne teuren boden
kaufen zu müssen
[Applaus]
liebe kollegen von der union zwischen
sozial und ökologisch gehört kein oder
zur dauerhaften senkung von lohnkosten
gehört beides zwingend zusammen die
preissteigerung für fossile heizkosten
belasten die bürger ungemein ein
beispiel der preis für heizöl ist im
vergangenen jahr um unfassbare
144 prozent gestiegen heizen mit gas und
öl ist so teuer wie nie und besonders
betroffen davon sind menschen mit einem
geringen oder mittleren einkommen da sie
häufiger an schlecht sanierten wohnungen
leben müssen
da ist es richtig dass wir handeln und
jetzt den heizkostenzuschuss auf den weg
bringen dann wollen wir dass mieter
vermieter dilemma überwinden im detail
warmmiete einsteigen und so die
modernisierungsumlage abschaffen noch
eine weitere maßnahme duldet keinen
aufschub
schnellstmöglich müssen wir auch das
vorkaufsrecht für kommunen rechtssicher
anwendbar machen sehr geehrte frau
ministerin geiwitz ich begrüße daher die
zeitliche priorisierung diese aufgabe
wie sie es gestern im ausschuss
angekündigt haben
die als ampelkoalition haben uns viel
vorgenommen und dazu gehört auch die
einführung der neuen wohn
gemeinnützigkeit in den 90ern hatten die
damalige cdu geführte bundesregierung
die wunde gemeinnützigkeit abgeschafft
und damit als eines der großen
grundprobleme auf den wohnungsmärkten
überhaupt erst entstanden wir werden die
wohn gemeinnützigkeit wieder einführen
wir werden die mietpreis bremse
verlängern und bis 2030 und das finde
ich sehr wichtig und sehr gut dass sie
es in der rede im erwähnt haben die
wohnungslosigkeit in deutschland
überwinden
liebe frau ministerin liebe kolleginnen
ich freue mich auf unsere zusammenarbeit
vielen dank
[Applaus]
kollegen wer kann das wort allah will
ich darauf hinweisen dass kommunen das
wunderbar ich diesen hinweis nicht
enthalten
nächster redner ist der kollege party
fraktion ebenfalls seine erste
parlaments
[Applaus]
der präsident frau ministerin meine
damen und herren führen hier heute viel
von zu hohen mieten gestiegene baupreise
angeblich notwendigen mietpreis bremse
und überhaupt von vier
irgendwie bezahlbarem oder eben nicht
bezahlbarem wohnraum und nun soll alles
besser werden aber all das sind nur
symptome es im zeichen dafür dass der
markt seit einiger zeit stark in
bewegung ist auch der wohnungsmarkt ist
ein markt mit angebot und nachfrage die
älteren von cdu und fdp erinnert sich
vielleicht aber warum ist das so warum
besteht ein mangel an wohnraum und die
preise steigen fast überall vor gut 20
jahren 2000 wende war das gerade eben
nicht so da gab es stark nachlassenden
nachfrage
was denn nun anders und was passierte
überhaupt werden vor etwas zu wenig
vorhanden ist also ein mangel besteht
gibt s end gibt es weniger als gebraucht
wird dies kann daran liegen dass das
angebot an wohnraum knapper wird oder
auf einmal die nachfrage nach wohnraum
steigt wenn das passiert steige der
folge die preise also miete ist genauso
baukosten das sind zeichen für den
mangel so einfach kann es sein das
angebot an sammler in unserem land an
wohnraum das und da sind wir uns
wahrscheinlich einig ist nicht gesunken
es sind nicht tausende wohnungen
unbewohnbar geworden oder abgerissen
worden das gegenteil ist der fall es
1000 dazu gekommen aber die nachfrage
die nachfrage nach wohnraum und darum
geht es hier diese den letzten jahren um
ein vielfaches gewachsen und diese
nachfrage lässt sich im grunde auf drei
wesentliche punkte zurückführen erster
es gibt immer weniger kleiner und damit
insgesamt immer mehr haushalte die am
markt eigene wohnungen nachfragen werden
wir früher eine fünfköpfige familie eine
wohnung nutzte sie bis heute überwiegend
ganz oft ein- und
zwei-personen-haushalte
da anteilige flächenverbrauch wächst
entsprechenden 50 jahren waren es 15
quadratmeter pro kopf heute sind es um
die 46 gut verdreifacht das frisst
wohnraum und ist ein symptom für die
vereinzelung und vereinsamung der
gesellschaft diese ursache für die
politik wohl nicht zu stellen den griff
kriegen im gegenteil unsere gesellschaft
zerfällt weiter und das liegt wohl
maßgeblich an zerstörten zugehörigkeit
und verbindlichkeiten jedenfalls zum
teil ist dies sicher auch eine folge von
erfolgreicher grün-roter politik also
der propagierung von diversity
multikulti konsumkultur globalismus und
die unterminierung von familie und
nationen
zweitens gibt es die binnenwanderung
alle den zuzug in die städte und die
wachstumsregionen die leute wollen wegen
arbeitsplätze vorwiegend eben lieber in
halle an der saale leben als im
saalekreis oder lieber in köln hat in
der eifel leider an beiden forderten
gründen wird die politik so schnell
nichts ändern können das sind
langfristige entwicklungen und drittens
und drittens geht es um eine sache die
die politik schnell regeln könnte aber
laut heitz verschweigt es ist der
elefant im raum die masseneinwanderung
seit 2005 10
aussehen und gefördert von den
migrations süchtigen der alten und
genauso der neuen regierung anders und
weniger verständlich ausgedrückt wie die
herrschaften hier man muss sich einfach
mal drauf einlassen meine damen und
herren dass mehr menschen im land eine
höhere nachfrage nach wohnraum bedeuten
dafür muss man kein populist sein da
kann man einfach drüber nachdenkt und
schon hat man darauf aber
meine damen und herren ich
will mir die hand reichen eine botschaft
des friedens
aber selbst wenn wir die grenzöffnung
2015 und manche absehbaren entscheidung
dieser neuen ampel regierung irgendwie
gutheißt irgendwie kann man sich
trotzdem an einem generell muster stören
was hier dahinter liegt und weiter
voranschreiten wird denn politische
entscheidungen die sich generell in der
republik einwanderung zusammenfassen
lassen benachteiligen häufig leute mit
geringem einkommen meine damen und
herren das führt dann dazu dass diese
haushalte und wir steuern die wohnungen
für die hunderttausenden
neubürger bezahlen aber selbst kaum noch
wohnungen finden geschweige denn
bezahlbar sehr vieles was seit jahren im
land läuft und was diese region noch
vorhat führt dazu dass die
niedrigverdiener die last dieser
entwicklung auf dem wohnungsmarkt als
erster und am stärksten ertragen müssen
und teilweise verdrängt werden sie
müssen das schaffen was selbstgefällige
grün-rote rhetorik verspricht
aber
aber hören wir nicht was ich sage wenn
ich was ich sage sondern was die
fachpresse vor einiger zeit in der welt
geschrieben hat zitat die hohen fairen
wanderungsgewinne tolles wort durch
flüchtlinge und migranten verschärfen
die wohnungsnachfrage der wohnungsmarkt
wird enger und das insgesamt steigende
mietniveau wird sich sukzessive auch im
bestand aufgrund von mieterhöhungen im
rahmen bestehender verträge und durch
höhere neuvermietung smeaton aus so
einfach und weiter zitat gerade jene
wohnung die an flüchtlinge verletzt
werden tauchen den einschlägigen online
immobilien parteien nur selten auf da
die gemeinden diese oft direkt und ohne
umweg über den freien fuß markt anbieten
beispiel gefällig gerade zwei drei tage
alt pressemitteilung der stadt
niederkassel oz meine heimatregion vom
elften januar 2022 zitat aufführung der
erhöhten zuweisung afghanischer
flüchtlinge sucht die stadt niederkassel
dringend private wohnraum zur anmietung
für diesen personenkreis für flüchtete
mit dauerhaftem bleiberecht ist ein ganz
wichtiger meilenstein bei der
integration ihre neue heimat wenn sie
eine eigene wohnung beziehen können wie
schön was ist mit den anderen alten
einheimischen auch deutsche oder andere
menschen die schon lange leben nur zur
erinnerung afghanistan zum bevölkerung
seit dem jahr 2000 bis heute von 18 auf
38 millionen menschen verdoppelt hat
kaum noch mehr und das hat nichts mit
den taliban zu tun gar nichts riskiere
weiter diesmal aus einem fachartikel bei
der größten deutschen tageszeitung zitat
die ausland zuwanderung insbesondere die
der flüchtlinge seitz vor 15 zielte und
zielt vor allem in die verdichtung räume
und metropolen zitat ende und dort gebe
es einen effekt ausgerechnet im
marktsegment der günstigen wohnungen
heißt es weiter der kampf um wohnraum
findet folglich im unteren segment statt
dort von migranten auf einheimische
treffen und das beruhigt und freut den
grünen migrations wichtigen und die
besserverdiener von cdu oder fdp denn
diese müssen all das in ihren rotwein
spöttern der städte nicht erdulden weil
sie dann nicht wohnen die menschen
hinkommen aber
[Applaus]
wir haben herrn man muss kein experte
sein um festzustellen dass über eine
million flüchtlinge in wohnungen
brauchen die lage auf dem wohnungsmarkt
für die eine bevölkerung fehlen der
reicht der gesunde menschenverstand und
dieser zuzug hört nicht auf jedes jahr
kommen mehrere grossstädte dazu dieser
zug endet derzeit ja kabul demnächst
vielleicht muss ich schon und der satz
wir haben platz ist eine lüge eine lüge
zu lasten aller heimischen in diesem
land die nicht das einkommen eines
abgehalten haben wer das dennoch
behauptet ist ein wohnungsnot ursachen
leutner und teil des problems die
einzigen die einzigen sofort fertig die
einzigen die derzeit etwas höheren
deutschen wohnungs charakter zählt die
poren in ihrer ostgrenze sie liebe ampel
regierung könnten das auch tun indem sie
zunächst etwa die 300.000
ausreisepflichtige ausländer abschieben
abschieben schafft wohnraum
nürnberger kollege
nächste rednerin in der debatte ist
carina konrad stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp fraktion im
deutschen bundestag
zunächst ist die kollegin carina konrad
fdp fraktion
ja ja der präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen mehr fortschritt wagen so
steht es über unserem koalitionsvertrag
und dieses motto scheint mir nicht erst
seit dem vorredner dringender nötig denn
je
mehr fortschritt ja sagen dass freien
demokraten ein herzensanliegen in allen
bereichen und die ampel hat sich viel
vorgenommen die ampel hat sich auch viel
vorgenommen im neuen bundesministerium
für wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
und das ist dringend notwendig denn
nicht erst seit korea ist das zuhause
für viele menschen mehr als ein ort zum
übernachten
es ist lebensraum ist arbeitsraum es ist
lernraum es ist raum für die eigene
entfaltung und für die eigene
entwicklung und dabei sind die
vorstellungen vom wohnen so individuell
wie die menschen in unserem land wir
haben uns auf einen maßnahmenmix
verständigt und der soll dafür sorgen
dass gutes wohnen bezahlbar und eigentum
kein luxus ist dazu muss mehr dazu muss
schneller und dazu muss günstiger gebaut
werden in den städten und auf dem land
und frau ministerin gallwitz hat einige
wichtige punkte bereits gesagt ich
möchte noch einmal welche hervorheben
die uns freien demokraten besonders am
herzen liegen wir wollen erstens das
wohnen bezahlbar bleibt dafür braucht es
keinen staatlich festgelegten mieten
deckel dafür braucht es auch keine
enteignungs fantasie sondern maßnahmen
die dazu in der lage sind die
angebotslücken zu schließen wir haben
uns eine offensive für bezahlbares und
nachhaltiges bauen und wohnen
vorgenommen unser ziel sind die 400.000
wohnungen zu bauen jedes jahr die so oft
erwähnt wurden dabei kommt es nicht nur
darauf an dass gebaut wird das sondern
es kommt auch darauf an was gebaut wird
und damit dieses ambitionierte ziel
erreicht werden kann werden private
investitionen der schlüssel sein und
diese privaten investitionen wollen wir
anreize das siebte mensch und der
wirtschaft das ist sozial ökologisch und
ökonomisch meine damen und herren und
zweitens ist es kunst freien demokraten
ein besonders wichtiges anliegen das ist
mein zweiter punkt dass ich mehr
menschen ihren traum vom eigenheim
erfüllen können das wird im moment
schwerer sie haben die gestiegenen
preise hier bereits angesprochen doch
wer für die erfüllung seiner träume
spart wer für sich und seine familie
eigentum wie das eigene haus aufbauen
möchte wer dadurch eigenverantwortliche
vorsorge auch für sein leben dem alter
betreibt wer so handelt er muss sich
auch darauf verlassen können dass seine
rücklagen etwas wert bleiben und wir
schaffen mit zahlreichen maßnahmen mit
unserem koalitionsvertrag die
voraussetzungen dafür dass mehr junge
menschen den schritt ins eigentum wagen
können einen freibetrag bei der
grunderwerbssteuer soll eingeführt
werden und so gerade zu beginn der
finanzierung den menschen die notwendige
luft verschaffen zudem unterstützen wir
mit eigenkapital ersetzenden darlehen
sowie tilgungszuschüssen und
zinsverbilligungen beim kauf einer
immobilie denn es ist doch meistens
nicht die monatliche rate die die den
weg ins eigenheim erschwert sondern es
in die anfangs finanzierungen und diese
hürden wollen wir abbauen
und mein dritter und letzter punkt ist
damit wir überhaupt bauen können
brauchen wir und frau ministerin gates
hat es angesprochen wir brauchen auch
leute für die bob der baumeister der
held ihrer kindheit war wir brauchen
fachkräfte laut ifo-institut findet
inzwischen mehr als jedes dritte
unternehmen im baugewerbe nicht genügend
personal so meldeten im oktober 34
prozent der unternehmen einen mangel an
fachkräften den fachkräftemangel im
bauwesen zu beheben das ist die
dringlichste aufgabe doch wie schaffen
wir das eine ausbildungsoffensive für
bauberufe wäre ein guter anfang bauern
heutzutage dass es mehr als steine
aufeinander zu stapeln es gibt hier
zahlreiche spannende komplexe und
hochtechnisierte bereiche am bau werden
bald junge technisch interessierte leute
mit augmented reality ihren und über
building information modeling den
digitalen zwilling als maßstab für das
bauen von morgen machen der bau braucht
junge technisch interessierte frauen und
männer die diese chancen von der vision
zur realität bringen und daran müssen
wir arbeiten meine damen und herren und
sie haben es angesprochen wir brauchen
auch qualifizierte zuwanderung in diesem
bereich dazu gibt es viele dicke und
dünne bretter zu bohren und unsere akkus
das kann ich ihnen sagen wir sind
geladen packen wir's an
die
politik conrad
[Applaus]
das habe ich gar nicht zu hoffen gewagt
dass er so schnell
nächste rednerin ist die kollegin carola
fraktion die linke
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren die durchschnittsmiete
in münchen liegt inzwischen bei über 19
euro pro quadratmeter
die heizkosten haben sich im letzten
jahr mehr als verdoppelt ob
kindergärtnerinnen oder grundschullehrer
ob krankenpfleger oder busfahrerin wer
kann sich das denn überhaupt noch
leisten
und ob sich diejenigen die hier den
laden am laufen halten auch in zukunft
noch eine wohnung in der stadt leisten
können das entscheidet sich jetzt
unter unserer städte lebendig und sozial
durch mich bleiben oder zu reichen
ghettos werben wie london und paris auch
das entscheidet sich jetzt und die
letzten acht jahre waren acht verlorenen
jahren es waren acht jahre des mieten
wahnsinns und der unterlassenen
hilfeleistung für mieterinnen und mieter
das darf sich nicht wiederholen
nun will ich skeptisch ob das mit dem
vorliegenden koalitionsvertrag gelingen
wird ich freue mich zwar sehr über ihr
persönliches engagement frau ministerin
gewächs finde es auch gut dass wir jetzt
einen baum ministerin haben ein eigenes
bauministerium prima dafür haben wir als
linke lange gekämpft genauer gesagt für
einen wohnungs ministerium aber leider
ist das neue ministerium jahr ein rumpf
die zuständigkeit für gebäude energie
liegt bei der wirtschaft für häuser und
grundstücke bei finanzen und für das
mietrecht und das schmerzt mich am
allermeisten beim justizministerium bei
der fdp das ist wirklich schade dass
neue
bauministerium darf kein feigenblatt
ministerium sein
das mantra der ampel lautet ja wie auch
das der letzten regierung bauen bauen
bauen aber es kommt ja darauf an was
gebaut wird und für drei viertel der
wohnungen gibt es der neu gebauten
wohnungen soll es gar keine vorgaben
geben also wieder teure mietwohnungen
teure eigenheim aber das geht am bedarf
vorbei es fehle in deutschland fünf
millionen sozialwohnungen darauf muss
der fokus liege nun
haben sie ministerin freunde sagt
hunderttausend sozialwohnungen aber im
koalitionsvertrag stehen 100.000
geförderte wohnungen das ist was anderes
also bitte keine mogelpackungen an
dieser stelle
mit ja versprochen ist eine milliarde
euro kommen sie nicht weit davon wurden
bis jetzt
25.000 sozialwohnungen im jahr
finanziert wir brauchen dann eine
dreimal so viel um die wohnung mit
auszugleichen die jahr für jahr aus der
sozialbindung fallen das ist doch völlig
absurd und deswegen brauchen wir mehr
geld für den sozialen wohnungsbau und
ein neues prinzip einmal sozialwohnungen
immer sozialwohnungen das muss in
zukunft gelten
hamburg ist ja ihr vorbild in der
wohnungs und in der politik aber kurz
ich kam eine studie heraus sie belegt
dass in hamburg die mieten mit 7,3
prozent so stark gestiegen sind wie seit
20 jahren nicht mehr das kann kein
vorbild sein und deswegen ist bauen
allein kein programm was wir dringend
brauchen das ist ein mieten stopp
wobei diese förderung so richtig und
auch so logisch ist hatte sie die spd ja
zum beispiel auch im wahlprogramm stehen
im koalitionsvertrag findet sich davon
kein wort auch die ausnahmen bei der
mietpreis bremse bleiben bestehen kein
wort zum kündigungsschutz keine
verbesserung bei gewerbemieten und auch
die bogen politik enttäuscht und nur ein
prüfauftrag beim vorkaufsrecht obwohl es
hat durch das urteil faktisch außer
kraft gesetzt wurde wir haben schon
geprüft und einen eigenen antrag
vorgelegt das vorkaufsrecht muss sofort
wieder gelten und es muss verbessert
werden
und zu guter letzt alle damen und herren
ist sie für mich so aus als hätten in
diesem koalitionsvertrag viele für die
bauwirtschaft gekämpft und keine für
mieterinnen und mieter wir als linke
werden weiter mit den mieten verbänden
mit den initiativen für den mit stop
kämpfen der mieten wagen sind muss
gestoppt werden dass monopoly muss
endlich beendet werden vielen dank
wie kann wohnen bezahlbarer gemacht
werden wie kann aber auch der wohnsektor
klimaschonender gestaltet werden darum
geht es hier unter anderem in der
debatte denn der klima gebäudesektor ist
für fast ein sechstel der deutschen
treibhausgasemissionen
zuständig bei nadal druck spricht jetzt
für die spd fraktion
keine woche keinen fall
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich will nur eine kurze bemerkung machen
der bag kampf sie sind ja jetzt neu im
ausschuss auch ich habe gedacht wird
sich irgendwas ändern aber es ändert
sich eigentlich überhaupt nichts
deswegen würde ich sogar außerhalb von
corona zeiten darauf verzichten dass sie
mir die hand reichen so wie sie das
thema
angemessen zu angemessenen zudem die
sirenen angemessene reaktion angemessen
ich lasse diese pflege lacht und
anmerkungen mich zu damit sie dazwischen
herrscht
ja ok ihre fakten also wenn es ein
äußeres zeichen gibt ich reg mich ist
doch schirmen sie sich aufregen machen
sie so weiter lauter mich stören sie
nicht ich hab das mikrofon könnte hof
verlassen also wenns hat als du bist
feuchten meine damen es gibt dafür dass
es einen aufbruch nach der
bundestagswahl gibt dann ist es die
tatsache dass es hier ein neues
bauministerium gibt das finde ich
nämlich großartig es ist nicht mehr die
frage ein appendix im bmg an der seite
wenn ich mal so sagen da auf einer
verheimlichten heimat abteilung sondern
ein neues ministerium wird die aufgabe
also den bau neuer wohnungen das
klimagerechte wohnen das bezahlbare die
bezahlbaren mieten übrigens auch karin
und die zukunftsorientierte
stadtentwicklung behandeln dann können
sie ganz sicher sein und lieber kollege
lutscher wir sind ja jetzt auch sie sind
ja im ausschuss das ist auch nach
aufwertung aber sie können sich darauf
verlassen dass die bauwirtschaft darum
bin ich zutiefst überzeugt unsere
ministerin anders als in der letzten
wahlperiode nicht nur aus prospekten
persönlich kennen wird kenneth magowan
seite zwischenfall ist im leben
mit einer neuen ministerinnen und ich
bedanke mich sehr dafür liebe vorganges
dass sie die erste möglichkeit hatten
genutzt haben mit uns im mit uns
parlamentariern im ausschuss zu sprechen
haben wir sofort gemerkt und gelernt wie
engagiert sie bei der sache sind konkret
und kompetent haben sie ihr
aufgabenspektrum dargestellt herzlichen
dank dafür wir freuen uns sehr auf die
zusammenarbeit es ist ja tatsächlich
nötig
400.000 neue wohnungen als jährliches
ziel darunter 100.000 sozialwohnungen im
jahr zu projektieren die ersten mittel
sind dafür jetzt schon freigegeben
deswegen wird es auf dem weg gehen und
es geht dabei tatsächlich nicht nur um
masse es geht nicht nur um kubikmeter
bauten umbauten raum es geht um die
vielfalt des wohnens um die jungen
familien es geht um die studierenden um
die auszubildenden es geht um die
wohnungs gemeinschaften um die barriere
barrierefreiheit und mietwohnungsbau und
natürlich auch um die eigentumsförderung
mietkauf beispielsweise es durchaus
angesprochen um genossenschaften in
ländlichen und in urbanen räumen überall
haben wir diese herausforderung zu
bewältigen und es geht eben nicht nur um
bauen bauen bauen sondern es geht um die
frage des richtigen baums des energie
und klimagerechten baums angebunden an
den öffentlichen nahverkehr
verdichtet den lebenszyklus der
materialien berücksichtigen
kostenbewusst digitale plan seriellen
vorgefertigt und übrigens mit lebendigen
öffentlichen plätzen und lebenswerten
innenstädten auch das gehört dazu wie
kann das eigentlich gelingen ja klar mit
einer menge zusätzlichen geld kann das
gelingen mit einer hohen
investitionsbereitschaft mit der
steuerlichen hilfe wie der erhöhung der
leeren abschreibung von 2 auf 3 prozent
beispielsweise mit verbesserungen beim
mieter strom mit eigentumsförderung in
genossenschaften und vielen weiteren
maßnahmen auch aber es reicht im
ergebnis nicht und jetzt liebe caren lay
will ich etwas sagen was zuständigkeiten
angeht ich bin sehr dankbar dafür dass
die ministerin sehr früh und sofort
davon gesprochen hat ein bündnis für
bezahlbares wohnen einzuleiten denn es
müssen alle an einen tisch wenn das
gelingen will da geht es nicht um die
zuständigkeiten zwischen zwei
ministerien sondern da geht es darum
dass wir eine konzertierte aktion zum
gelingen der aufgabe organisieren eine
gesellschaftliche aufgabe unter
federführung eines zuständigen
ministeriums mit einer engagierten
ministerin das ist eigentlich das ziel
dabei war der ganzen aufgabenstellung
die reduktion der treibhausgasemissionen
ist übrigens dabei nicht die einzige
aufgabe das was uns in europa
vorgetragen wird unter dem motto fit for
fifty five das wird uns noch gewaltig
herausfordern die fachkräfte frage
selbstverständlich auch die
rohstoffknappheit die unterbrechung von
lieferketten beispielsweise die
durchsetzung der digitalisierung im
bausektor das alles gehört zu dieser
konzertierten aktion mit langzeitwirkung
dazu und um die werden wir uns kümmern
und dazu gehört übrigens auch richtung
bauwirtschaft das gute arbeit gut
bezahlt wird und dass die mindestlöhne
und der gesetzliche mindestlohn nicht
sozusagen unterschritt wird und die
bauwirtschaft ist gut dabei beraten das
hatte eine anfrage die ich selber
hergestellt habe auch hervorgebracht
dass sie sozusagen ihre eigenen
schwarzen schafe dabei
sozusagen korrigiert denn ohne gute
löhne wird es keine fachkräfte geben
ohne gute löhne gibt es keine
auszubildenden und das alles ist dabei
auch erforderlich leider leider habe ich
nicht die zeit und all die fragen zu
beantworten die ich gerne kommentieren
noch sagen würde weil ich leider zu
anfang eine kleine ein kleines boot
hatte deswegen will ich zum abschluss
aber auch noch sagen mich freut es auch
frau ministerin genauso wie sie dass die
raumordnung einen ort gefunden hat wo
sie ernsthaft behandelt werden kann wo
fragen beispielsweise der raumnutzung
auch der windenergienutzung
beispielsweise dazu benutzt werden
kommen verfahren zu verkürzen kommunen
zu entlasten die sache selber
voranzubringen das geht wirklich breit
angelegte aufgabenstellung wir freuen
uns auf die zusammenarbeit herzlich
willkommen herzlichen dank und
in anderen schönen abend
in seiner kollegen
die fraktion hat vom eine prävention
gebeten für den kollegen wettkampf ich
lasse die kurzintervention zur kohle
bekannt sie haben das wort
[Musik]
ja lieber darum sie hatten gerade noch
mal ja gesagt dass sie ihn hier
zukünftig nicht die hand geben das
bedaure ich ich gebe nach wie vor die
hand und das auch sehr gerne wir uns
gerne über eine fakten unterhalten über
die wir gerade in meiner rede was gehört
haben das können wir gerne auch mit
quellen und belegen machen und zukünftig
wünsche ich mir von ihnen dass sie ein
bisschen mehr mit niveau pöbeln vielen
dank
dafür wird sie wollen darauf dass
ehrlich antworten ich wollte darauf
hinweisen dass ich auch nicht an die
hand gebe weil das ja nicht angemessen
ist wird der chor ohne chemie nie aber
sie können ganz so
habe ich überhaupt nicht gebügelt und
fakten dargestellt
so damit ist das jetzt hoffentlich auch
erledigt nächsten rednerin ist die
kollegen peter nicolaisen cdu csu
fraktion
aus schleswig holstein wo die ruhigen
menschen wohnen
das stimmt sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrte frau ministerin in einer
generaldebatte zum thema
stadtentwicklung wohnen und bauen
vermisse ich einen blick darauf welche
bedeutung die bundespolitik in diesem
bereich für unsere kommunen hat denn sie
haben die kommunen als anhängsel in
ihrem ministerium
und ich gestehe zu sie haben aus
kommunaler sicht die latte recht hoch
gehängt im koalitionsvertrag so heißt es
im aktuellen koalitionsvertrag
wir brauchen leistungsstarke und
handlungsfähige kommunen unser ziel sind
leistungsfähige kommunen mit einem hohen
maß an entscheidungsfreiheit vor ort
eine verlässliche öffentliche
daseinsvorsorge und eine engagierte
zivilgesellschaft
doch kann dieses ziel mit einem
koalitionsvertrag von spd grünen und fdp
erreicht werden ich meine nein der
koalitionsvertrag
hemmt kommunale planungs kompetenzen und
schränkt die kommunale selbstverwaltung
ein vielmehr streben die koalitionäre ca
zitat eine engere zielgenauere und
verbindliche
kooperation zwischen bund ländern und
kommunen an wo bleibt denn da die
kommunale selbstverwaltung
der koalitionsvertrag enthält zudem
risiken und nebenwirkungen die ländliche
räume aber auch städtische
ballungszentren belasten werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen was
bedeutet dies konkret so haben wir zum
einen die wechselwirkung zwischen stadt
und land wer diese nicht berücksichtigt
verschärft die situation in unseren
kommunen
statt diese zu verbessern werden mit dem
geplanten bau von 1,6 millionen neuen
wohnungen in überwiegend städtischen
ballungszentren die ländlichen räume
durch wegzug geschwächt und die
städtischen ballungsräume zunehmend
belastet und es muss frau ministerin
also auch bei der infrastruktur in
betroffenen ländlichen regionen hier
nachgelegt werden ein beitrag zu
gleichwertigen lebensverhältnissen
leistet die regierungskoalition damit
nicht und genau das ist auch mein
nächster punkt die gleichwertigen
lebensverhältnissen diese wagens waren
koalitionsvertrag bei verschiedenen
ansätzen adressiert aber bei der
konkreten regierungsarbeit wird das
thema voraussichtlich keine bedeutende
rolle spielen so werden neben einigen
bereichen die im rahmen der
gesetzesfolgenabschätzung einen check
unterzogen werden sollen gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse nicht einbezogen und
das der gleichwertigkeit check bereits
in den vergangen war in der vergangenen
woche rio de tablett worden ist von uns
kann dafür nicht verantwortlich sein
denn andere themen schecks sind
ebenfalls bereits in der gemeinsamen
geschäftsordnung der bundesministerien
enthalten und werden dann auch im
koalitionsvertrag nochmals genannt die
wechselwirkung zwischen stadt und land
allein beim bau von wohnungen zeigen
aber wie wichtig ein gleichwertigkeit
check in der gesetzesfolgenabschätzung
ist und das kann problemlos auf andere
bereiche ausgeweitet werden hier muss
die regierungskoalition dringend
nachbessern und so wie es in den
vergangenen in der vergangenen
wahlperiode ja bereits vereinbart worden
ist gesetzesvorhaben auf auswirkungen
auf das ziel gleichwertiger
lebensverhältnisse prüfen
als einen weiteren punkt lassen sie mich
einige worte zur stärkung der kommunalen
planungshoheit sagen ein wesentliches
element kommunaler selbstverwaltung ist
die kommunale planungshoheit und das
geht für flächennutzungspläne und
bebauungspläne deren ausweitung durch
das auslaufende regelung des paragraphen
13 baugesetzbuch erschwert wird und
insbesondere das entwicklungspotenzial
kleinerer kommunen in ländlichen räumen
hemd
kommunale planungshoheit wird aber auch
beim ausbau der windenergie beschnitten
werden hier will die regierungskoalition
in rechtsbereiche eingreifen für die der
bund nicht zuständig ist zentralistische
vorgaben werden die kommunale
planungshoheit im baubereich jedenfalls
nicht stärken sondern die kommunale
selbstverwaltung schwächen
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen insgesamt
lässt der koalitionsvertrag für die
kommunale selbstverwaltung
wenig hoffnung auf gute zeiten statt
bundes einmischung wäre mehr vertrauen
in die kommunalen fähigkeiten auch im
sinne des ziels leistungs die kommunen
zu haben zielführende ich persönlich bin
der meinung dass es einer intelligenten
neugestaltung der aufgaben und
aufgabenverteilung und der finanzmittel
zwischen bund ländern und den kommunen
bedarf nur dann können wir die kommunen
auch in die lage versetzen ihre aufgaben
und herausforderungen aus eigener kraft
zu bewältigen
mit weniger bundesvorgaben und mehr
freiheit vor ort erreicht man
tatsächlich leistungsstarke und
handlungsfähige kommunen herzlichen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
nächster redner in der debatte ist
casillas alle er ist obmann im ausschuss
für wohnen stadtentwicklung bauwesen und
kommunen für bündnis 90/die grünen und
redet ihr im bundestag zum ersten mal
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
mein name ist krass und daher solle ein
bauingenieur bündnisgrüner sachse und
bin entschlossen den notwendig
sozial-ökologischen umbau im bausektor
voranzutreiben
denn
denn gerade hier müssen wir tatsächlich
mehr fortschritt wagen auch im jahr 20
21 hat der gebäudesektor das klimaziel
nach dem klimaschutzgesetz deutlich
verfehlt über 33 prozent der weltweiten
co2 emissionen stammen aus dem
gebäudesektor an vielen orten habe statt
als pause als bauleiter persönlich
gesehen tonnenweise beton und
kunststoffe werden gebaut obwohl das
große co2 schleuder sind
es fehlen es fehlen außerdem
klimafreundlichere elemente wie wärme
punkten vor der wollte begrünte dächer
und fassaden
das ist gelinde gesagt energetischer und
ökologischer bullshit meine damen und
herren
aber nach jahren des stillstands unter
horst seehofer wird es mit hilfe der
neuen ampel koalition jetzt endlich
vorangeht wir bündnisgrüne haben immer
wieder eine bau wende gefordert und sie
kommt jetzt auch denn wir werden
400.000 wohnungen jährlich klimaneutral
bauen wir werden neue technologien den
weg bereiten und gleichzeitig auf
ökologische baumaterialien um rohstoffe
zurückgreifen die verbände
die verwendung von holz werden wir im
zuge einer nationalen holzbau strategie
ausweiten mit dem neuen digitalen
ressourcen pass können wir diese
baustoffe in der dokumentieren und somit
den gesamten lebenszyklus im blick haben
das ist die zukunft und schon bald die
gegenwart des bauens meine damen und
herren
schon bald wird sich das logan etabliert
haben auf dieses holz können wir bauen
gleichzeitig möchte ich hier und heute
deutlich machen wohnen ist ein
grundrecht und dass wir alle liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das
gilt ganz besonders für wohnungs und
obdachlose die studierenden azubis die
menschen mit niedrigen einkommen wie
gefürchtete für menschen im alter und
für menschen mit behinderung und
eins sage ich ihnen ganz egal ob sie
kasse jam klarer oder olaf heißen der
name oder die herkunft darf nicht über
die wohnung entscheiden
eine solche art der rassistischen oder
klassischen diskriminierung ist unsozial
und menschenunwürdig das gehört endlich
beendet meine damen und herren
dazu stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
wir schaffen das alle menschen würdevoll
wohnen können das geht nur mit
zukunftsgerichtete um nachhaltigen bauen
das tatsächlich allen zugute kommt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ein sozial
ökologischer umbau bereich heißt damit
konkret wir brauchen bezahlbare wohnen
für alle menschen und wir werden dies
mit den ökologischen herausforderungen
beim bauen im einklang bringen dafür
stehe ich persönlich
dafür stehen wir als bündnis grüne und
bei diese kraftanstrengung stehen wir an
ihrer seite frau ministerin vielen dank
worte macht an klara geywitz
gerüstet die neue ministerin für
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
nächster redner in dieser debatte ist
auch
eventuell zu einer zusammenarbeit bereit
dahin fürst ist er von der fdp also auch
eine der qualität parteien erst in
seiner fraktion sprecher für bau und
wohnungspolitik
sehr geehrter herr präsident werte frau
ministerin
die ampel pläne sind sehr ärgerlich beim
bauen und wohnen im gesamten
koalitionsvertrag die sind aber auch
deshalb sehr ehrgeizig weil wir
unheimlich viele hausaufgaben geerbt
haben jetzt habe ich die
verhandlungsgruppe bauen und wohnen für
die fdp geleitet und festgestellt also
an der spd lag das scheinbar nicht
muss ich sagen ich freue mich auch dass
auch die ampelkoalition beim bauen und
wohnen bewirken könnten bewegen wird und
wenn ich da geht's um die reden auch
höhere werte kolleginnen von der cdu/csu
dann wissen wir aber auch klar warum so
wie hausaufgaben da sind
lieber herr lux ihr wisst ja ich schätze
insbesondere die kollegen von bauen und
wohnen aus euren reihen aber die
mietpreis bremse gilt nur in
angespannten wohnungsmärkten und wenn
die ampel das tut was sie versprochen
hat nämlich bis zu 400.000 wohnungen im
jahr zu bauen dann werden wir schnell
erleben wie angespannte wohnungsmärkte
der vergangenheit angehören und so löste
das problem mit der mietpreis prinzen
und deswegen freut mich auch sehr dass
wir im koalitionsvertrag dann auch
festgestellt haben dass die
angebotslücke das große problem ist und
nicht die die die fehlende regulierung
dafür müssen wir ein oder anderen stelle
nachschärfen aber das große versprechen
haben wir gegeben dass wir schnell
günstig neuen wohnraum schaffen und da
liegen die da liegen die mechanismen auf
der hand wir haben doch jedes mal
vorgeschlagen in den letzten jahren nach
aufstockung der boden ist bereits
bezahlt geht modular geht in
holzständerbauweise geht schnell
digitalisierung des gesamten prozesses
es ist doch völlig absurd dass wir für
die dafür für den wohnungsbau längere
genehmigungsverfahren haben als die
bauzeit dauert das muss gelöst werden
sie haben völlig zurecht angesprochen
die die über komplexität ist bauen die
20.000 regenarmen gesetze vorschriften
natürlich müssen wir da ran deswegen
haben wir im koalitionsvertrag auch
festgelegt dass wir uns mal die normung
anschauen vier jahre lang gar nicht
beantwortet oder bearbeitet worden wir
haben festgelegt dass wir einen
wohnkosten check einführen der darauf
achtet dass jede neue regeln darauf
achtet welche und wie die neue regel auf
die wohnkosten zählt weil wer günstiger
baut der kann am schluss auch günstiger
wohnen und das ist einer ganz großen
hebel
kollege dezember zu einer wirklich sehr
guten ersten rede angesprochen
zumindest angedeutet ich mache noch mal
ganz deutlich
wenn der gebäudesektor bei der co2
einsparung bei der emissionseinsparungen
nicht liefert dann werden wir die
pariser klimaziele niemals erreichen und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir die
fördersumme systematik endlich umstellen
dass wir den fokus richten auf die
tatsächlich gesparte menge co2 und weg
davon kommen einzelne maßnahmen zu
fördern sondern das gesamtsystem in den
blick nehmen inklusive des quartiers
inklusive der art und weise wie die
wärme erzeugt wird und inklusive der
effizienz des gebäudes und uns ganz
wichtig inklusive der technik die
möglich ist so werden wir schnell starke
mengen co2 ansprachen
abschließend nämlich gern einen einsatz
von ihnen auf frau ministerin muss
zugeben der start der zusammenarbeit er
hat sehr viel spaß gemacht wird gut sie
haben formuliert wenn ich jetzt die
schnelle richtig gemerkt habe wohnen ist
kein luxus
absolut korrekt unterschreibe ich
ergänze eigentum ist auch kein luxus
eigentums traum erfüllen eigentum ist
leistungsanreiz eigentum ist sicherheit
eigentum ist das was die menschen wollen
deswegen freut freien hat dass wir sagen
wir brauchen freibetrag bei der
grunderwerbsteuer das können die länder
machen aber wir gehen in die
eigenkapital ersetzt nur darlehen mit
tilgungszuschuss und helfen den gegen
dies gerade nicht schaffen ins eigentum
zu kommen wir haben viel zu tun die
ampel macht sich auf den weg bauen und
wohnen wenn ihr mit der weisheit liebe
cdu csu mich freut es die menschen haben
es verdient dass die wohnkosten sinken
vielen dank
die rednerinnen ist die kollegin
franziska schenk spd fraktion ebenfalls
mit ihren ersten parlamentswahlen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr geehrte damen und herren
mein land heißt wahlkreis leipzig ist
sehr vielfältig es gibt einen
speckgürtel ringsum leipzig es gibt
vorwiegend landwirtschaftlich genutzte
und geprägte regionen es gibt aber auch
industrie
kohlebergbau und kohleverstromung und es
gibt viele abgelegene ruhige orte mit
überwiegend älteren menschen
wie sie denen meine damen und herren in
meinem wahlkreis gibt es viele
herausforderungen
ich bin froh dass diese fortschritts
koalition diese aufgaben in den nächsten
jahren angehen wird die
spd-bundestagsfraktion
wird sie und insbesondere frau
bundesministerin klara geywitz dabei
tatkräftig unterstützen
wir werden viel angeben angehen die
insbesondere die menschen in den
ländlichen räumen betreffen da ist
beispielsweise das altersgerechte wohnen
viele menschen eben gerne in ihren
wohnungen oder in ihrem häuschen und
wollen dauert dort auch ihren
lebensabend verbringen
dazu werden nicht nur energetische
modernisierungen nötig irgendwann werden
wir alle hilfe und unterstützung
brauchen darum benötigen wir vielleicht
barrierefreie türen oder sanitäranlagen
neue formen des zusammenlebens wie
seniorinnen ggs oder die
mehrgenerationenhäuser werden immer
wichtiger um die wohnliche umgebung auf
die bedürfnisse der älteren menschen
abzustimmen dazu zählt auch das
leerstehende bestandsgebäude in den
kommunen für altersgerechtes wohnen
genutzt werden können hierfür braucht es
flexible gestaltungsmöglichkeiten im
baurecht denn letztlich ist auch dass
eine frage der nachhaltigkeit und trägt
zum erhalt der innenstädte besonders
kleinere kommunen bei
mir in der spd-bundestagsfraktion wollen
barrieren abbauen und somit mehr
selbstbestimmung ermöglichen deshalb
möchten wir die beliebten und wirksamen
kfw programme erhalten und ausbauen
meine damen und herren ein zentrales
vorhaben in dieser koalition ist der
klimaschutz
gerade im gebäudebereich ist eine ganze
menge zu tun wir freuen uns dass mit den
kolleginnen und kollegen der anderen
ausschüsse anpacken zu können hierbei
werde ich aber dafür dass wir die
bedürfnisse in den ländlichen regionen
nicht aus den augen verlieren und uns
immer wieder fragen die wir diese
anforderungen in weniger dicht
besiedelten gegenden angehen und
gemeinsam mit den menschen vor ort
umsetzen können
meine damen tragen
für mich und für die menschen in meinem
wahlkreis ist das ein bedeutender punkt
bei allem was wir hier besprechen
leidenschaftlich diskutieren und
gemeinsam beschließen müssen wir uns
immer wieder vor augen halten welche
unterschiedlichen ausgangsbedingungen in
unserem land herrschen denn es gibt
viele orte gerade auch bei mir im
wahlkreis in den kommunen den gürtel
immer enger schnallen müssen es selbst
in einem stadtrat wie mit engen
finanziellen mitteln und ehrlich gesagt
ohne und auch diese engstirnige
schuldenbremse der sächsischen union
sind hier gar keine hilfe die wir also
mit wirklich winzig finanziellen
handlungsspielräume dazu kommen dass
wichtige aufgaben wie zum beispiel die
jugendarbeit wieder gestrichen werden
bei kein geld da ist da drohen gerade
viele möglichkeiten der
gesellschaftlichen teilhabe zu
verschwinden immer mehr vereine
freiwillige feuerwehren und
zivilgesellschaftliche initiativen
springen für den staat in die bresche
das fordert die ehrenamtlichen
ordentlich und hinterlässt bei einigen
menschen doch irgendwie den eindruck
dass es immer weniger möglichkeiten zur
persönlichen entwicklung im ländlichen
raum gibt und dass das leben und
arbeiten auf dem land immer
unattraktiver wird da hilft es nicht
wenn dann auch noch die apotheke der
bäcker die post oder die gerade in
meiner stadt die sparkasse denise dicht
machen diese erfahrungen prägen die
menschen und sie prägen auch ihre
einstellungen zur demokratie bei all
diesen punkten geht ist jetzt das ruder
rumzureißen denn die kommune ist die
letzte meile zu den bürgerinnen in der
demokratie wir müssen bauliche aber vor
allem soziale infrastrukturen stärken
und somit auch mehr teilhabe ermöglichen
für mich ist
das eine grundlegende voraussetzung für
soziale gerechtigkeit einem durch und
durch
sozialdemokratischen ziel packen wir es
an vielen dank und ein herzliches
glückauf
[Applaus]
der nächste redner in der debatte ist
ulrich lange stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzende für die
unionsfraktion hier in dieser debatte
ministerium für wohnen stadtentwicklung
und bauwesen
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
kollegen frau ministerin
auch wir gratulieren natürlich zum neuen
ministerium baupolitiker haben es weiß
gott herbeigesehnt dass das zurückkommt
was rot-grün damals abgeschafft hat aber
auch das sei lediglich eine historische
randbemerkung es ist spannend dieser
debatte zuzuschauen die diese neue
koalition heute uns hier bietet denn ich
habe liebe kollegin schröder und lieber
kollege voest
noch nicht so ganz den gemeinsamen bogen
gefunden man kann natürlich fühle
wünsche erstmal formulieren und ein
füllhorn draus machen einen aufbruch
kann ich dabei aber wirklich nicht
kennen viele prüfaufträge viele
forderungen aber sind die ressourcen da
sind die zuständigkeiten da in diesem
neuen ministerium
liebe frau ministerin ja wir freuen uns
über das neue ministerium
aber sie brauchen ein haus mit
zuständigkeit und kompetenz und keine
gebäudehülle warum sage ich das weil
vieles halbherzig ist weil vieles nicht
fertig ist an diesem haus um ein
wirkliches
bauministerium zu werden und das erkennt
man auch hier an dieser debatte wird
debattieren immer wieder dinge für die
sie frau ministerin und auch der
bauausschuss keine federführung hat wie
stellt er die frage der
modernisierungsumlage die von seiten der
grünen so in den mittelpunkt der rede
gestellt wurden ist es ist geregelt im
bgb und der neue justizminister busemann
der fdp sitzt ja schon da und da sind
wir ja mal gespannt wie die grünen
vorstellungen zu den vorstellungen der
fdp beim thema modernisierungsumlage im
justizministerium
zusammenpassen wir haben das thema
gebäude energie wir waren uns ja gerade
von einig wie wichtige energie hier im
sektor bauen ist und dann stellen wir
aber doch wieder fest dass dieses thema
im
wirtschaftsministerium geblieben ist
frau ministerin auch da fehlt ihnen was
und dann ich sage es ganz offen die ganz
große enttäuschung wie oft haben wir
gesprochen dass wir auch die grundstücke
und flächen und gebäuden der bima in der
politik doch gerne zugreifen würden und
wenn wir das jetzt richtig nach verfolgt
haben dann bleibt das thema beamer im
finanzministerium also auch nicht im
bauministerium dieses ministerium ist so
stückwerk liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ja wir wollen bauen wir brauchen wir
brauchen stadtentwicklung aber wir
brauchen es richtig
1,6 millionen wohnungen haben sie sich
vorgenommen
die sage 1,6 4 x 400 tausend sind 1,6
millionen wohnungen haben sie sich
vorgenommen das bedeutet aber auch dass
sie sie bauen müssen wer soll sie planen
wer soll sie bauen wo sind die
ressourcen wo ist die fachkräfte
offensive baum wo ist an das im
koalitionsvertrag im bau- und
wohnungswesen zeige aber die wohnungsbau
offensive die wir gestartet haben soll
fortgesetzt werden 2009 150 tausend
wohnungen
2020 300.000 wohnungen wir haben
vorgelegt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben vorgelegt und das wird nicht
so einfach ich kann viel freude aber am
ende
muss es dem realitäts trick erfüllen wir
haben das thema der vorschriften kollege
ludwig
lutter kartfahrer angesprochen verlegung
war noch von kollege ludwig hat von
angesprochen auch dagegen sie
blankoschecks blankoschecks die am ende
zur zwangs sanierungen führen und dann
sprechen sie über eigentum der fdp rückt
das thema eigentum in den mittelpunkt
die frau ministerin da habe ich zur
eigentumsförderung überhaupt nichts
wirklich vernommen und bei den grünen
habe ich vernommen im ausschuss gestern
dass endlich 16 jahre investoren politik
ein ende finden muss liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der fdp wir brauchen
investoren und das wissen sie doch ganz
genau ohne investoren kein wohnungsbau
sie können sie sitzen ja jetzt
nebeneinander dann auch mal besprechen
und erklären 16 jahre waren 16 jahre
waren auch geprägt von einer gemeinsamen
politik acht jahre davon hat die spd die
bei politik verantwortet von einer
gemeinsamen politik ich will es nur mal
so als anmerkungen sagen der bremse da
können wir jetzt über vieles diskutieren
bauland zu mobilisieren ist und bleibt
eine hauptaufgabe
dazu wird es wohl eine neue novelle des
baugesetzbuches geben die kolleginnen
und kollegen der letzten periode kennen
diese herausforderung ich sag nur 13 b
ja das brauchen wir auf dem land ich
sage aber auch endlich brachflächen
programm wer nicht will dass wir
permanent neue eco gute böden für
bauland verwenden der muss und darf
nicht weiter brachflächen programme
blockieren wie es die sozialdemokraten
in der letzten periode getan haben
wir müssen die innenstädte
revitalisieren frau ministerin das war
zu wenig nach der pandemie die 250
millionen respekt die kamen aus der
letzten periode die milliarde für die
klima respekt die kamen aus der letzten
periode kommt ja wir müssen etwas tun
für die innenstädte wir brauchen mehr
programme liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
es geht um lebensqualität es geht um
quartier es geht um gleichwertigkeit der
lebensverhältnisse es geht um
wohnungsbau schwung nicht um
luftschlösser daran wollen und werden
wir sie messen dann kuscheln
du hast dann kommen wir zum letzten
jeden an dieser debatte
es ist carolin otte sie ist für mitglied
von bündnis 90 die grünen im deutschen
bundestag und sitzt im ausschuss
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte frau ministerin geibert sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen mit
einem koalitionsvertrag starten wir
diese regierung der die lebensrealitäten
von menschen in den blick nimmt und sich
zur aufgabe macht diese spürbar zu
verbessern
bitter genug dass die erwähnenswert ist
was eigentlich grundsätzlich aufgabe von
politik sein sollte aber viel zu selten
in den letzten 16 jahren unions
regierung der grundsatz war
vieles von dem was wir hier in berlin im
bundestag beraten und beschließen vieles
von dem was eine bundesregierung auf den
weg bringt kann nur umgesetzt werden
wenn wir nicht an den kommunalen
realitäten vorbei entscheiden hier
werden wir im zuständigen ausschuss ein
auge darauf haben aber auch unsere
regierungskoalition hat sich dies ins
stammbuch geschrieben denn unsere
vorhaben können wir nur mit starken
kommunen vor ort realität werden lassen
wir brauchen die städte und gemeinden
damit unsere politik bei den menschen
vor ort ankommen kann
für das kommende jahr hat sich die ampel
das ziel gesetzt planungsvorhaben zu
beschleunigen damit es vorangeht
energiewende vor ort realität wird damit
1,6 millionen neue wohnungen gebaut
werden können damit wir endlich einen
zügigen zubau von china erreichen
mit der schärfung des kommunalen
vorkaufsrechts erweitern wir kommunaler
handlungsspielräume und begehen begegnen
wohnraum spekulationen und verdrängungs
tendenzen aber gebaut gekauft oder
saniert wird nur da wo man nicht in
schulden zu ersticken droht
fast 150 milliarden euro kommunale
investitionsrückstand das sind keine
schulden in den büchern
aber in der bitteren realität
wenn hier über desolate schultoiletten
reden dann müssen wir auch über die
kommunale finanzlage sprechen wenn wir
hier nicht anfangen dann bricht die
kommunale daseinsvorsorge weg das
kommunale schwimmbad die bibliothek wird
geschlossen das krankenhaus privatisiert
die buslinie gestrichen das trifft vor
allem die menschen die den wegfall nicht
mit privaten einkommen ausgleichen
können das dürfen wir nicht zulassen
für die sicherung der kommunalen
daseinsvorsorge und zur realisierung der
notwendigen investitionen ist es
wesentlich dass wir überschuldeten
kommunen helfen und sie nicht mit ihrem
sozialausgaben alleine lassen
fördermittel wir müssen wir gerade für
finanziell belasteten kommunen
niedrigschwellig gestalten damit
öffentlich gebaut wird müssen wir den
fördermittel dschungel anfassen
ausschreibungskriterien vereinfachen
unser grundgesetz gibt das versprechen
von gleichwertigen lebensverhältnissen
dieses versprechen ist lange nicht
eingelöst aber besonders in zeiten einer
globalen krise ist solidarität und
gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt so
wichtig beides muss vor ort spürbar
werden vor ort müssen wir klarmachen mit
starken sowie daten kommunen dass wir
für die menschen einen unterschied
machen packen wir es an
vielen dank frau grüne lehnte weitere
wortmeldungen liegen dessen
themenbereich nicht vorher
[Applaus]